all of a sudden like six months later
it's in the trailer
as the great bob ross once said we don't
make mistakes just happy accidents cut
cut off hurt myself god stop quickly get
the medic over the course of filming a
movie there will be multiple bloopers
and outtakes that never see the light of
day but every once in a while a blooper
is so good that the filmmakers decide to
actually keep it in the final movie
whether it's a forgotten line a real
injury or just some genuine laughter
from the cast these are the times a
blooper was too good to cut from a movie
i can't believe that just happened i was
like what he just smashed the real
guitar star-lord is a savior of the
galaxy but that doesn't mean he's
perfect during the scene when he
presents the orb that contains the power
stone to the collector he fumbles the
object awkwardly dropping it and quickly
picking it back up this may seem like it
was written for the character but it was
actually a blooper by chris pratt it was
completely by accident but the ever
professional pratt stayed in character
director james gunn loved it and kept it
in the film
[Music]
draco malfoy is known for his propensity
to insult anyone around him including
his friends it turns out malfoy actor
tom felton fully embodied the role as he
added some insults of his own in the
chamber of secrets when harry and ron
are undercover as crab and goyal malfoy
notices goyal is wearing glasses and
asks why he's wearing them to which
goyal replies
um reading tom felt and forgot his next
line so he improvised channeling his
inner malfoy reading
i didn't know you could read you may
remember the scene from the princess
diaries when mia slips and takes a hard
fall while walking on the bleachers this
was a complete accident as anne hathaway
actually fell it had rained the day
before so the bleachers were still
slippery hathaway explained that
director gary marshall kept it in the
movie because it was a charming moment
if it was good it was in the movie he
didn't care where it came from he didn't
care what happened who knew a coatrack
would be worthy of wielding thor's
hammer apparently chris hemsworth who
hung the hammer on the rack as a gag it
was an improvised moment that chris did
as a joke but the filmmakers actually
kept it in the movie we have to wonder
if that coatrack now possesses the power
of thor if he be worthy she'll possess
the power of thought have you ever
noticed that tony stark is always
snacking whether it's pizza doughnuts or
a classic cheeseburger iron man always
seems to have food in his hands the
reason for this is because robert downey
jr was actually snacking constantly
while on set he did it so much that the
filmmakers just decided to write it into
his character in one scene from the
avengers downey goes off script and
offers mark ruffalo some blueberries
which you can see catches him by
surprise come on here you can have a
peach
thank you
sometimes the best take of a scene is
the one where the reaction is real when
aragorn kicks a helmet in a scene from
the two towers actor viggo mortensen's
visceral reaction is genuine as he broke
two toes during the scene they filmed
multiple takes of this scene but it was
on the fifth and final take in which the
accident happened director peter jackson
was impressed with how the actor pushed
through with the scene i mean he stayed
in the character of aragorn he was
letting that pain feed and drive his
performance which is pretty amazing
dwayne johnson has proved himself as an
all-around talent an action star a
comedian and a master of improv in a
scene from the fast and furious six
dwayne johnson's character walks into a
backyard barbecue and tyrese gibson's
character roman pearce jokingly says hey
mia you better hide your baby all
johnson replies better hide that big-ass
forehead
this moment was improvised and
completely caught ludacris off guard he
does a spit take as he couldn't hold
back his laughter and they kept it in
the movie because of how funny it was
ben stiller plays the not too bright
model derek in zoolander he embraced the
character especially in one scene when
stiller forgot his line after david
jakov's new character explains to
zoolander why male models are
brainwashed zoolander asks again but why
male models it's perfectly in character
for zoolander but his co-stars weren't
expecting the blunder and their
confusion can be seen in the movie you
serious i just
i just told you that a moment ago add
clumsy to the long list of donald
glover's attributes in a scene from the
martian glover's neurotic character
rushes away from his desk and in the
process slips and falls glover actually
fell and his co-star's reaction is one
of genuine worry
are you all right
it's fine glover didn't let the slip up
rattle him though as he continued with
the scene he stated that director ridley
scott loved it and didn't need to do
another take of the scene the lord of
the rings trilogy is one of the most
well-crafted movie series ever put to
screen but even it got some assistance
from mother nature and some lucky timing
when eowyn stares off into the distance
a flag flies off its pull it's a
beautiful moment that has been seen as
an intentional metaphor included by
director peter jackson but it was
actually an accident it was worked into
the scene though and you could see
actress miranda otto react to the
unexpected moment
can you imagine destroying a forty
thousand dollar piece of history kurt
russell can during the filming of the
hateful eight there's a scene where
russell's character takes a guitar and
smashes it they were using a 19th
century martin guitar on loan from the
martin guitar museum for jennifer jason
lee's character to play they were
supposed to cut before russell smashed
it and swap it out with an ordinary
guitar but russell didn't get the
message and obliterated the guitar so
then i found out later that that guitar
was was the real gibson i guess jason
lee's reaction is genuine as she reacts
with horror at the sight of the historic
guitar being destroyed lee says russell
felt terrible because he had no idea
that he was destroying such a valuable
guitar music time's over
heath ledger's portrayal of the joker is
legendary he brought the character to
life and gave him a unique feel unlike
any joker before him one example of
ledger's mastery of the character came
during the scene when he is in jail and
gordon is promoted to commissioner when
the police start clapping to
congratulate gordon the joker also
starts clapping along with them the
moment wasn't in the script and was all
ledger you can see the other actors
surprised at the gesture and they
decided to keep it in because it
perfectly reflected who the joker is and
i thought my jokes were bad robin
williams masterful improv skills turned
a blooper into a memorable moment in mrs
doubtfire williams had to wear a face
mask of icing for the scene but the heat
from the set lights started to melt it
and chunks of it dripped off his face
instead of cutting and reapplying the
icing they let robin continue with the
scene as he went with the flow and
ad-libbed his lines to make it a comedic
moment and it works wonderfully as you
can see i can't stay with you there i'm
melting like a snow cone in phoenix jay
barachel was forced to face his fears on
the set of knocked up in the intro scene
of the movie jay and his three friends
can be seen riding roller coasters at a
theme park bear rochelle's terror is
real as he has a serious fear of
coasters he was so scared he offered to
get naked during the movie instead but
director judd apatow finally convinced
him to ride and you can see the fear and
regret in jay's reactions luckily he
only had to ride it once i started
having like a major freak out the
infamous waxing scene from the 40 year
old virgin is one of the most iconic
scenes in comedy movies a big reason for
this is steve carell's reaction to
getting his chest waxed for real
as his ridiculous cries of pain were all
genuine the laughter and reactions from
his co-stars are all real too as they
couldn't help but laugh at the bizarre
scene the actress waxing him lied during
her audition saying she had done waxings
before when in reality she didn't know
what she was doing carell actually said
the actress's real name which can be
heard in the film oh mika you should
burn in hell we'd be willing to bet he
won't ever be doing that again it was my
idea too so i don't like myself to blame
we loved seeing these genuine moments
make it into the final cuts of the movie
for an industry that is extremely
meticulous about every aspect of
creating a film it's fun to see a real
unscripted moment make it to the big
screen sometimes you just need to
embrace your mistakes which blooper was
your favorite